mastering middlegame ideas and um well
it's a very very broad topic and that
often times before I approach any tart
topic I try to break it down into what
everybody calls their five elements
right so we have in chess the element of
space space controlling lots of squares
we have the element of time or
development getting our pieces out as
rapidly as possible we have the element
of material just who's ahead and was
that a good sacrifice or not then we
have the element of pawn structure and
finally King position okay so while a
lot of us are aware of these elements we
don't genuinely tend to use them we
don't play a game and go holy cow look
at this that pawn structure is the
Carlsbad pawn structure I know that and
now I know what to do and so forth and
so on but as we get better in chess we
really start learning how to use the
pawn structure to create plans and
overtime in a very very short period of
time ideas about the middle games and
structures have really evolved and
they've evolved very very quickly
structures that we thought were bad for
example the sveshnikov sicilian as a as
a structure that gives white a great
outpost on the d5 square they would have
been discarded a hundred years ago is
simply unplayable so a lot of structures
a lot of thinking about middle game
structures has really changed and this
was really driven home to me many years
ago by my friend bent Larsen so we were
talking about openings and bent head
explained that when he was a young boy
he had purchased a book in Danish that
was published in 1920 and the book
professed to speak to every opening and
regarding the caro-kann the book
explained that this move was bad and the
author assigned a question mark to that
move and he said that in this position
as white all you needed to do was play E
for takes d5 C takes d5 c2 c3 and stop
the chapter completely with and white
stands much better okay so why in 1920
did that author was pretty good player
by the way I forgot his name and the
discussion like whites better because in
those days it was considered that from
the pawn structure black has the open
half open C file White has the half open
efile that whites rook was going to be
much more effective on the half open
efile and that white is going to use the
e5 square as an outpost this pawn on c3
limits whatever rook is going to appear
on c8 and White's better white this that
today we think that for example Bishop
d3 the first move or the third move
knight c6 c 3 let's say Knight f6 Bishop
f4 and a lot of people have argued that
and White's better but in this position
after c3 oops excuse me in this position
yeah just second
if I do it right there it is all I have
to do is hit enter yes black should
immediately play Bishop f5 of course
okay so why was it in 1920 this
structure considered better or even much
better for white why because up to that
time nobody knew about the minority
attack nobody played the minority attack
the minority attack is simply in that it
was it was okay it was established that
from your pawn structure you should play
with your majority their idea is that
White's queenside majority is going to
be used long term and that when you play
Knight f3 and Bishop d3 and castles and
bring your Knight to e5 you're basically
neutralizing blacks majority so this
idea of a minority attack was unknown
and the minority attack really played a
crucial role in changing the evaluation
of many many many opening systems and I
from my own practice I'd like to give an
examples of the minority attack in
action how many of you are familiar with
minority attack how many of you've
played minority attacks yourselves okay
so there you go uh some of you are going
to find out something very interesting
okay so I am white and this game I was
played in 1983 in the town of Nixon
Montenegro what was then Yugoslavia what
is today Montenegro and I playing
Michael tall okay whenever you're
playing Michael tall you understand
right away you don't want to mix it up
with this guy
okay you did there do's and dont's let
me forget about pawn structure yeah this
is about playing your opponent so what I
wanted for Michael tall was a nice quiet
strategical position and I must tell you
at this very moment and move for
three-four black I was really sweating
that he would play c5 and going to some
lines of the minami because they can get
really sharp and I don't think after C
Phi Y could really gain an advantage
with the move III but I'd have to accept
the challenge of D Phi fortunately for
me Michael tall went into my favorite
system which is a classical nimzo-indian
system with Queen c2 we have d5 takes
takes Bishop g5 so these moves are all
very very well known and black plays h7
h6 and now the main move considered
White's best is Bishop h4 new variation
white black could do it all kinds of
different ways but let's say g5 Bishop
g3 Knight e4 and we can get a really
wild game with bishop coming to f5 on
coming to c5 sometimes black tries to go
h5h for trapping lights bishop it gets
to be a really wild game and again I
didn't want to have anything to do with
that I took the night okay that's one
piece off the Lord Queen takes f6 a-two
a-three now in view of the fact that
Bishop f5 loses a piece to Queen a4
check and the bishop is taken as well as
the fact that if the bishop moves I'm
going to take this pawn on d5 tiles move
is forced okay so that's two pieces off
the board
got rid of those guys castles typical
tall he's offering me the opportunity to
play Queen takes e7 and mix the game up
no thanks III same offer Bishop f5 once
again
offering me two pawns this time Queen
takes e7 rook c8 Queen takes b7 96 or 97
and well I just got a lot of pieces on
the background so no thanks to that pawn
offer and I like pawns okay so now we've
got our structure and what I'm trying to
do now from white side is I want to play
B foot I'm expecting that at some moment
he's going to play c6 and the minority
attack is I'm going to play B for a 4 B
5 and my goal is to saddle black with a
backward pawn on c6 once I could get
this pawn on c6 as a target that's all
I'm playing for a very very small
strategic aim
I played 92 developing a night played
rook c8 again what tal is advertising is
he wants to play c5 and mix up the game
again I want nothing to do with that
Knight g3 Bishop drop back play b4 now
this move basically essentially closes
the door once and for all black is not
playing c5 but a mission was quite
stubborn and he clung to his ideas so
here we have mission in full battle mode
wanting to open up the position playing
a5 one of the key
strategies in middlegame positions and
it goes like this it's really
fundamental and rather simple you don't
want to play your opponent's keen in
other words if your opponent is seeking
to make play on the queenside usually
it's a good idea to ignore your opponent
and to develop play on the kingside for
example in this position it could be
easily argued that you could play G 6 H
5 H 4 H 3 and create some weaknesses on
White's camp and when you battle your
opponent on his turf you have to be very
very certain that the outcomes going to
favor you because you're really playing
into your opponent's strengths so in
other words don't be fooled by whatever
it is that you think your opponent is
doing but pursue your agenda so when
when my opponent when when Misha played
a5 I was absolutely elated I mean I
still have a lot of work ahead of me to
develop my pieces and again to try to
one day force my opponent play c6 and to
saddle him with a weakness on b5 and
this move helps me a great deal Bishop
e2 takes takes takes takes Queen isse
Evan Queen c3 Knight c6
again a very very helpful move for me
because it's clear I want from literally
the start of the opening I want to put a
pawn on d5 and he's encouraging me to do
it with a gain of tempo it would have
been far better for Misha to change
direction at this point and possibly
play 97 and put his knight on c4 or
continued with the idea of 90
seven knight f6 page four and Knight
coming to e4 so it's like my lucky day
my opponents helping me out and again I
really like trading off those rooks to
who the tactics you know the the cheaper
potential of the physicians going down
and down and down and down with each
trade I tack the night the night goes
back castles okay so now you know again
it's not one of those positions that's
going to win any immortal game prizes or
anything like that it's just you know
cold solid chess where my goal at this
point might be for example to play rook
c1 change my rook and queen around and
then again figure out how to target some
weaknesses in blacks position the really
hardship that black has is White has no
pawn no weaknesses when your opponent
has no weaknesses to target it makes it
really hard for your opponent to play c5
again a dream come true
Tawes walking right into what I could
have only I could describe this as the
ideal position that is to say I've
achieved the maximum I possibly can
because I've managed actually my
opponents with my phonons help I managed
to saddle him with a weak pawn on c6 so
rook c1 in order to ensure that the on
stays on c6 and doesn't advance okay so
now Bishop d7 we can see what Kyle wants
to do let's go night here and pawn here
okay in the meantime it's not like my
pieces are are doing anything particular
in other words this night on g3 I can
think of like five more squares that
would be very much more favourable c5 e
5 b6 to name but three
by bishop on e to also seeking
improvements that's what a lot of middle
game is about - is constantly constantly
looking at your own pieces and saying
are you doing the best job you possibly
can would it be more effective of my P
my piece was in a better Square and
probably the two supreme players who are
fantastic about doing that were Tigran
Petrosian and Anatoly Karpov
whenever you absolutely thought that
they had put their pieces on the very
best possible squares they found a way
of finding even a better square in this
case again it's not like my pieces are
particularly effective these guys are
pretty good
neutralizing this pawn or keeping in its
place so to speak but here's a clear
example of a superior square for my
Queen Queen a5 just controls a lot more
squares makes black worry about a
potential pin really kind of puts
further the kibosh on c5 because now d5
is going to be under a latent attack
okay King f8 this was too deep not sure
I fully understand this only that misha
may have been thinking that in case of a
pin the bishop can move easily enough
queen a7 bishop out Queen b6 again I'm
reasoning that my Queen on c3 is simply
much better placed on b6 then on c3 make
it kind of hard for that night on d8 to
move clearly I'm going to have to do
something with my minor pieces in short
order but for the moment it's just
repositioning my pieces to better
squares Queen c7 Queen b1
a reminding black that maybe his King
belongs on g8 after all Misha agrees
Bishop d3 again nothing major is going
on here
just an improvement of Bishop Queen goes
back to e7 again suggesting that he
would like to play c5 Queen c2 stopping
c5 and now this is actually a very
important note my strategy would really
have come a cropper if ninety seven was
a good move fortunately for night for me
Knight d7 would be a terrible move and I
simply play Bishop a6 and eliminate that
night in the resulting position there
would be a knight versus Bishop position
that the bishop is a poor piece because
of the pawn structure one of the great
mmm riddles puzzles questions what's
better the Bishop per day how many thing
the bishop how many prefer the knight
interesting and in the 18th century
Knights were favored those those
romantic players they loved to to to
throw their Knights into the into the
attack and Knights were tricky only in
the 19th century did the did it tilt to
favor the bishops in today's modern
grandmasters they heavily favor the
bishops but you have people like Ben
Larson who actually preferred Knights he
felt that bishops were overrated and in
his famous victory over Bobby Fischer
from the Piatigorsky Cup it was two
knights versus two bishops and the
Knights were dancing so okay so now
pardon me so now with this move Bishop
d7 what is tall thinking can somebody
tell me why Michael tall
the move Bishop d7 defending his c6 pawn
yet again
Julian yeah I think it was ninety sixty
five so I gave him a check just to see
where he would go this is actually a
very common idea not just exclusive to
grandmasters but just simply very strong
players you never know when a check that
forces your opponent or drives your
opponent's king to the corner when you
get that opportunity play it if it
doesn't injure you in some way because
you never know that what if you know the
position were to explode and you're in
the king upon end game you'd love to get
that what with that black King one
square away from the center and if ever
I got into a race with my king well I'll
have gained maybe a crucial opportunity
so check bishop defy Bishop f5 and now
I'm welcoming the 97 96 move because I
want to take that night so Michael tall
was much happier trading his Bishop I
played Knight takes f5 Queen d7 and now
I've got a problem I mean I've done
really good I think I mean about as good
as I possibly can but if he gets to play
96 and c5 he'll liquidate his backward
pawn on c6 whatever winning chances I
have really knows died so how can i
interfere with his plan
need a good idea need a good suggestion
not so easy dancing man it's not a bad
idea actually
efore s not bad if I if he takes takes
we're both going to have a little bit of
weaknesses but after E for I think you
would still play 96 I could trade on d5
and Queen no hold on I can't do that
sorry
so e4 is very legitimate move the my
intention whoops my intention is that I
would recapture with the Queen but I'm
overlooking a trick I apologize so that
would probably necessitate takes takes
Knight e6 again it's one of those things
where I think the drawing margins higher
than my winning chances better
legitimate idea yeah I actually thought
in a different direction the knight
looks good on f5 but it really doesn't
do anything it doesn't pack a punch if
we were to just to shift it over one
little square the knight would actually
be far superior on e5 what Knight HP 96
Queen uh-huh okay so now I got some
tricks in mind that go like this what
happens when he plays c5 can you
calculate that out can you calculate
that out what would happen after c5
Joey CPUC thinking thinking thinking can
you see it yeah
do you K did you calculate it it up
no takers okay let's have a look let's
have a look so c5 d take c5 rub take c5
rook takes e5 Knight takes e5 Queen
takes mm sorry there's actually a choice
here white could also play Knight g6
check white is better but the game is
dead wrong
essentially the best I can do is I can
put my queen oops excuse me escape I can
put my Queen on d4 I can play F 3 e for
force a trade so I'll have a passer but
in a queen ending with the King the
black King so close to the e-file it
will be a draw my intention was to take
take
Knight of 5 now here it's very clear
what my intention is if black tries to
go King here and King here I'm going to
meet that with a check or Kingi a king
of that I'm going to meet that with a
check and I'm going to take the pawn I
want to play 1 2 3 4 takes yeah but my
knight is really annoying if for example
he plays Knight f6 King of King up King
up King up
my check King up the King is too far
away sorry I'm used to chess pace the
King is too far away from the d5 pawn I
will play f3 followed by King I'm going
to yeah okay control okay I want no yeah
there you go
I want to come I want to come up to
these squares with the King and notice
that black has stranded his King here so
what tile calculated was instead of this
he calculated h5 king over g6 now what
Tom's idea is he's going to make a
beeline as soon as the knight moves up
the board to e5 my intention was here
here here here here here and I had
thought that the game is drawn it was a
premature decision in the sense that
Michael understood inherently that with
my King on d4 I always have some tricks
that I might be able to exploit that
would tie him down into so we're going
to go back and this was why in the game
he did Queen isse Evan avoiding that
ending and funnily enough embracing a
different ending he wanted he wants me
to play Queen takes d5 rook c5 Roxy 595
and he wants to play Queen and Knights
versus and I have four verses three
jillion probably because it's bad
because it's very good sorry
so Queenie 7 I have to play g3 now this
was the crucial moment so now here is
where tall messed up you should play
rook takes e5 new variation rook takes
e5 Knight takes e5 Queen takes d5 and
play Knight and four versus queen night
and four and four versus Green Knight
and three I think black has very good
chances of drawing okay
White has very good chances of winning
but I think the draw is high for black
in time trouble and it gets away from
our point of the lecture Queen d7
question mark
I had c6 and now unfortunately he gets a
much much much worse version of Queen
and for the Queen night and four versus
queen Knight and three as now we have
two things going on we have pawn
structure and King position and blacks
Kings position is obviously much much
worse I think we got here and we
adjourned in those days they had such
things as a Germans and Talia's eine
without it without resumption so what we
saw in that game is that white from the
very opening was really going for this
minority attack and this was an example
of our opponent helping us okay so I
wanted to bring up a second game so it's
also very interesting when you go
through a lot of ground
master games that you can see that a
overriding theme or motif is standing
out in their games so in this particular
game
my opponent yup who been a very very
strong master in Holland we were playing
in the Dutch league what I wanted to say
is that it very often happens that you
will get a isolated Queen pond position
so I'm just going to put a isolated
Queen pond position on the board and
it's like the whole game revolves around
that isolated Green Pond so this is a
very famous literally starting position
and it's very very very transpositional
a lot of openings can get this identical
position from Queen pond King pond
sicilians carros Queens gambit declined
Queens gambit accepted and so forth and
so on and the pond strategy of playing
either with the isolated upon or against
the isolated pawn really dominates the
game for a very very long while here
again what I did want to talk about was
the minority attack in this game my
opponent gets let us say the good
variation in the minority attack he
developed his bishops is made it very
hard for me to get these guys going or
even hard for me to play e5 and so this
is a much much better version than the
of the minority attack for for black
then what Michael tall had against me a
seven a six ok this is my attempt
to get the opponent a little bit out of
book first of all I know that a long
long time from now I'm going to play D 5
a 7ex I also want to avoid this this
very very very well-known continuation
Bishop g5 Queen b3 Knight a6 Queen a4
Bishop d7 Queen c2 which was played way
back in the days of kappa blanka amongst
many others so a 7a 692 Bishop g4 Knight
f3 we'll come to it at a moment that
white also had a choice of Queen b3
we'll see how I would have answered that
Knight f3 e6 Queen b3 rook a 7 so
essentially transposition so it may look
a little bit ungainly that my rook is on
a7 for the moment because the position
is so closed it's not crucial whereas
maybe when I play b5 and before the rook
can swing across it's not going to be
bad and furthermore how long is this
Queen going to be on b3 is that a good
place for whites Queen castles Bishop d6
95 Bishop back rook e8 so Quick Poll
what's the consensus White's doing very
very well
blacks okay
Black's okay what well in a sense as we
can see from the position White's
developed everybody you know I'm at
least one and two Tempe behind in terms
of completing my development but my
positions really rock solid it's really
hard for white to launch an attack
that's substantive that has meaning I
Castle rookie three but that doesn't
prevent white from coming you know we
got to look up and over some ideas of
rook coming across through the H line
maybe to the G line playing for Bishop
h6 who knows or maybe simply doubling
rooks Bishop g6 always like those
bishops when they're in front of my king
like that you know it really makes me
feel very very comfortable we have a
trade trade Queen back to d1 well what
we can see here is that basically white
wants to make a maneuver where he can
use the half-open H line to play Queen
f3 to g3 to h4 and rook over it's going
to check make me I did you guys see in
the sync fell Cup a game between car you
wanna and who was it I think it was
Wesley so we're car you wanna has missed
the idea of Queen h8 check right King
takes it and that takes f7 yeah
so that's another ideas like when the
Queen lingers over here I have to be
careful not to leave this f7 pun okay
Knight h5 well now I'm just taking
matters firmly under control and I
really want to put a kibosh on whites
attacking ideas and Knight h5 does that
Bishop back Knight takes pawn takes
Knight takes pawn takes Bishop here
attacking the rook rook comes over I
went Queen g5 so at this point I was a
little bit concerned that my winning
chances of my opportunity to win I
really have to start mixing things up if
I continue with the standard b5 I was
afraid that my opponent would put a
knight on d4 where it would be very
handsome indeed so I went Queen g5 with
my own ideas not only of taking this
pawn but of course I really want to see
the move Knight f3
I can go queen takes g3 but I also have
ideas it may be a long long long time in
coming of actually exploiting the open
h-file
myself Knight b3 b7 b6 so here I'm
offering my opponent an opportunity to
change the pawn structure and if you
would like to take my bishop and I would
take and I have chances of exploiting
his weak Queen side pawns my opponent
declined the my kind invitation Julian
yeah Queeny to rook over to c8 Knight to
d4 rook over to c7 g4 not a hundred
percent sure that this was a very good
decision I think that what white feared
is that I was going to go b5 Bishop here
rook here b4 I'm trying again to create
a weak pawn on the c3 square
I think this move is a little bit of a
panic reaction that white is thinking
that perhaps you can go rook over to h3
g3 King g2 and use the H file yeah I
took rook takes for obvious reasons my
opponent didn't want to recapture with
the pawn again in that case I'm the
proud possessor of the only open file in
the position so we could pretty much
suggest that rook takes d4 was forced
ruk to c4 okay I still haven't given up
on my dream I have a dream
yeah b5 a5 b 4f for kicking my my queen
as far as white is concerned into
purgatory Viktor Korchnoi said it very
very well and he said it often pawns
don't move backwards okay so when you
move your pawn in front of your king as
did my opponent in this case f4 do be
aware do be consciously aware that a lot
of weak squares are created by that move
and I played the move Queen h4 just kind
of hanging around I do not have any kind
of a winning plan if you said to me how
are you going to win this I wouldn't be
able to answer you I don't know what I
do know
is that I want to improve my position
step-by-step I want to increase my play
over here and maybe who knows to harass
the structure a little bit more with
Queen g3 and possibly even to play g5
row Cobra b5 GFI so now my opponents in
shutdown mode right
he's just creating a fortress now this
pawn is untouchable he's creating a
fortress and saying I'm just going to
hold the position
solid oops
that's that's creating a weakness yeah
the idea behind this move is what
happens if he takes my font what's my
plan Julian and then after rook d1 rook
takes d1 and queen of four okay look
okay so the question is what happens if
he takes and Julian's half right rook d1
roopd rook t44 rook check rook here I
wasn't planning on playing rook takes
yes precisely if I play rook takes Queen
takes Queen takes I'm a little afraid
that this guy is actually a strong
bugger and you might play Queen here and
if he gets a runner I'm going to force
they get forced to give him a perpetual
check but after Queen takes f4 now he's
got issues because I'm going to be
several tempi up on that previous line
and here I'm threatening rook takes in
Queen takes as
as well as if it's my term maybe I just
play queen takes the other thing I can
do with my queen on f4 is I could start
to play d4 trade and go d3 and I got my
own runner so that was why my opponent
played pardon me Queen f3 takes takes
takes - oops yes
pardon me so now I have to plot myself
on the back right I got my I've got the
position I had always aspired to I'm
going to be if you get I'm going to
leave them with a weakness for the
moment f4 is hanging and that was why my
opponent played g3 okay so what do I do
now pardon queen h3 he'll take the pawn
queen f5 very good position for me yeah
very good position for me I actually
have a better move I think good good
yeah
I believe that's what I play yes Queen
h5 so in my mind's eye this is a dream
come true
if you would trade Queens pawn takes
pawn takes rook takes not only would I
be a pawn up but I have this beautiful
path straight up the board yes Julie
precisely yes that is actually the Ginga
so he cannot afford to trade queens he
cannot afford to move queens because I'm
taking the pawn on b2 so my opponent has
played g4 remember what Viktor Korchnoi
says these pawns they don't move back
I play Queen h4 on tanks and the
variation Julian pointed out I could
almost stop here and say that this again
is you know the minority attack and full
blossom a long long long time ago nobody
saw any winning plan in blacks position
with this b5 be for minority attack with
the idea of creating a weaknesses in
your opponent can is seen in so many
openings just for for fun sake I'll
finish the game and what happened
clearly my opponent has a passer so I've
got to I've got to be johnny-on-the-spot
here and I checked them around a little
bit I think that this was just for good
time control yeah and there was some
time control you know after past move 40
so now it's time to push my pawn and I
push my pawn again and I check them yeah
I'll sure better let her that was a good
one so uh what I'm saying is as you get
stronger as you you have more more
pattern recognition these elements this
pawn structure element is going to play
a greater role in your in your games and
maybe it'll just happen unconsciously
but you'll start recognizing aha in this
pawn structure this is a very good plant
this is very effective plant in this
pawn structure that's a very effective
plant and some when you go over
grandmaster games do keep an eye out for
that for pawn structures because that's
like a key insight into the position